und jetzt rein in den Ukraine Krieg der
seit einem halben Jahr mittlerweile
läuft und diese Bilder hier die zeigen
die überraschende Wendung in diesem
Ukraine Krieg nach einem halben Jahr die
ukrainische Armee sie greift offenbar
russische Stellung auf der Krim an eine
Gegenattacke also auf dem Gebiet dass
sich Putin 2014 unter den Nagel gerissen
hat
schwere Explosionen auf der von Russland
besetzten Halbinsel Krim die Videos die
seit Dienstag Nachmittag in den sozialen
Medien kursieren bezeugen einen
strategischen Wechsel der ukrainischen
Militäroperation offenbar macht die
Ukraine Ernst greift nun auch von Putins
Armee und seinen Handlangern besetzte
Gebiete in größerer Entfernung an die
Explosionen auf der russischen
Luftwaffenbasis in der Nähe der Stadt
novofedo rifka reisen die Menschen aus
einer trügerischen Stille tragen das
Kriegsgeschehen jetzt auch vor ihrer
Haustür
[Musik]
ich war im Badezimmer und hörte
unfassbaren leer ich hatte das Gefühl
dass etwas Großes heruntergefallen war
dann lief ich zum Fenster und sah raus
es sah so aus als ob ein Atompilz von
einer Atomexplosion dort aufgestiegen
wäre es gab zwei große Explosionen wie
diese dann stürzte alles ein
[Musik]
nach offiziellen Angaben von russischer
Seite stirbt ein Mensch umgehend wird
behauptet auf dem Flugplatz seine
munitionsladung explodiert tatsächlich
ist davon auszugehen dass die Ukraine
die Luftwaffenbasis der Russen mit
hochmodernen Raketen aus den Beständen
seiner westlichen Unterstützer
angegriffen hat Liebe Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer heute richtet sich viel
Aufmerksamkeit auf die Krim und das zu
Recht denn die Creme des ukrainisch und
werden Sie niemals verleugnen wir werden
nicht vergessen dass der russische Krieg
gegen die Ukraine mit der Besetzung der
Krim begann dieser russische Krieg gegen
die Ukraine und gegen das ganze freie
Europa hat auf der Krim begonnen und
muss auf der Krim Enden durch ihre
Befreiung
es wäre der erste Angriff der
ukrainischen Armee auf die von Russland
besetzte Halbinsel Krim und das nicht
seit dem Beginn von Putins blutigen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine im Februar 2022
sondern seit März 2014 dem Start der
russischen Besatzung
[Musik]
Bild Reporter Björn Stritzel jetzt aus
der Ukraine und zugeschaltet hier gerade
in dem Moment reißt die Schalter ab nein
da bist du Björn ich grüße dich herzlich
in die Ukraine dort in den Osten des
Landes die entscheidende Frage
russisches
Militärgebiet dort getroffen durch
ukrainische Raketen oder ein Unfall auf
der russischen Seite dort auf der Krim
welche Hinweise hast du was kannst du
tun um aufzuklären
also die die Propaganda des russischen
Regimes das sich dabei wieder um einen
Unfall gehandelt hat so wie es auch
schon in den vergangenen
spontanmunitionsentzündungen Unfälle
gehandelt haben soll die halte ich dafür
nicht sehr glaubwürdig das ist eine
wahrscheinlich der wichtigste
Luftwaffenstützpunkt den die großen
errichtet haben auf dem besetzten
ukrainischen Territorium von dort aus
werden die Angriffe in der süddruckreine
geflogen unter anderem in der Nähe des
gesetzent in der südlich von
insofern dass dort einfach sich mehrere
Munitionslager spontan selbst Entzündung
halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich hat
die Ukraine den Raketen um so weit zu
schießen und so weit zu treffen
also nach
offiziellen Angaben nicht sie haben sie
haben in der Eigenentwicklung eine
ballistische Rakete die allerdings
bisher noch keine Tests absolviert hat
sie haben die
Seezielflugkörper haben die Neptun bzw
auch die das theoretisch auch erreichen
könnten mit mit der
landziel angreifen könnten sie haben
aber mutmaßlich auch mittlerweile
Munition für ihre heimatsysteme bzw für
die mlhs die die bis zu 300 Kilometer
weit erziele angreifen könnten das
bisher noch nicht offiziell bestätigt
dass sie über diese über diese Munition
auch verfügen aber das erscheint mehr
als die naheliegendste Variante jetzt
hat uns das ja alle überrascht alle
Experten waren überrascht dass dieser
offenbare ukrainische Angriff dort auf
der Krim passiert ist das so etwas wie
eine ja völlig überraschende Wendung in
diesem Ukraine Krieg nach einem halben
Jahr oder ist das eine einmalige Schlag
und da steckt im Grunde jetzt nicht mehr
dahin es läuft nicht Richtung
Rückeroberung der Krim
also ich glaube von der Rückeroberung
der Krim zu sprechen das ist natürlich
ein strategisches Ziel und das ist
sozusagen das was selensky ja auch
skizziert hat aber das ist nicht das ist
jetzt unmittelbar ansteht allerdings ist
es natürlich ein nach einem halben Jahr
hat Russland die sich ja selbst für die
zweitgrößte zweite schlagkräftigste
Armee der Welt halten es immer noch
nicht geschafft die Lufthoheit über der
Ukraine zur zur zu erhalten und haben
auch jetzt sozusagen damit zu kämpfen
dass ihre eigenen Basen mehr als 200
Kilometer entfernt von der Front
attackiert werden mit mutmaßlich
ballistischen Raketen mit Ja oder bzw
mit mit anderen Sachen von denen wir
noch nichts wissen insofern das ist
natürlich ihr habt von der Wende
vielleicht zu sprechen bisschen zu früh
aber es zeigt natürlich dass dieser
russische Angriffskrieg alles andere als
als dem entspricht was was Moskau
ursprünglich geplant hat mit dieser mit
dieser angeblichen 72 Stunden Operation
danke für deine Analyse Bild Reporter
Björn Striezel aus der Ukraine für Bild
live
[Musik]